today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video here's
a question that seems pretty basic and
pretty simple but it's really not quite
so straightforward how does an economic
recession or depression end in other
words we know that they happen and we
know that eventually they end but what
is the mechanism exactly we might be in
a recession right now we could be
heading into a depression right now this
could extend for months or years some
are saying to some degree we are going
to have very high unemployment for
several years at some point what we are
in will end unless this is the end of
planet earth how does it all end we know
that we have a lot of self-fulfilling
prophecies that can get us into a
recession but can those same
self-fulfilling prophecies get us out
now this is not we know when do we when
we say that something has ended this is
not about the statistic that tells us we
are out of the recession or the
depression we can argue about that and
some people would say well it's based on
GDP GDP tells you when you're out of a
recession what I'm talking about is not
how can we tell when we are out I'm
talking about what is the mechanism that
gets an economy out of a recession or a
depression is it that we see more hiring
and unemployment goes down is it that
the stock market goes up and makes
people confident is it just people's
confidence in and of itself which is a
cause versus an effect these are not
simple economic questions and what you
really need are two major things to get
out of an economic downturn first the
cause of the downturn needs to be
clearly resolved and then number two you
need a combination of economic policy
and business conditions to start an
actual recovery in terms of the numbers
but you also need consumer sentiment to
change this is a reality in economies
like ours that are heavily driven by the
perception of their own
State and that is that people fearing a
recession starting to spend less can
precipitate one but also people feeling
as though the situation has been
resolved and starting to spend more and
demand more in and of itself can help to
get us out of a recession so yeah people
feeling like the recession is over is a
big part of the recession being over and
it can seem recursive or endlessly
regressive this is arguably not good
about our economic system I think it's
important to understand that so much of
how we are doing as an economy is about
how people believe that we are doing but
for now this is our system and consumer
sentiment is part of getting out of a
depression because when people believe
we are out or soon to be out they start
acting as though we are out which gets
us out because people start spending and
demanding goods and services so let's
think back to 2008 ok the Great
Recession of 2008 two things happened to
stop that recession and to get us out of
it number one the underlying issue which
was the fear of huge financial
institutions being insolvent as a result
of the mortgage crisis and some other
reasons that was resolved sort of in the
sense that we had some new regulations
we had the belief that we've put in
place new lending guidelines so the
mortgage crisis can't happen again we've
cleaned up some corruption supposedly
even though nobody went to jail but the
point is there was the belief that the
underlying cause had been resolved that
was a big part of it in addition though
we had a lot of economic policy response
under the Obama administration that got
us out that included that huge stimulus
package that Republicans were furious
about that Barack Obama did it included
new government spending it included some
tax cuts so that was 2008 the difference
now with the current recession or what
some are saying is an inevitable
depression that's coming related to
coronavirus is that it is not a
financial institution recession in
principle what we have here is a corona
iris pandemic which decimated demand for
stuff because of the pandemic because of
the virus demand for travel went down 90
95 percent in some cases demand for
office space collapsed demand for
restaurants collapsed all of that stuff
so the resolution to this one is not
about government spending money or
sending people cash government needs to
do that as a stopgap so that people
don't starve or lose their homes or lose
their cars or lose their businesses that
they hope to go back to but the
underlying issue here to be solved is a
medical issue we need treatment we need
a vaccine so for now government's role
is a little bit different in this
recession than it was in 2008 government
needs to provide support for people to
keep them and businesses afloat in a
sort of waiting period it's a bridge in
a sense once the underlying issue of the
virus is resolved demand in principle
should start to recover now it's only
going to recover in proportion to
people's ability to demand things now
when we say demand we're talking about
it economically I can demand a private
jet in the sense that it sounds cool but
when I talk about economic demand it
means that there is actually the money
with which to demand these things in an
economic system so as people feel safe
going to restaurants they will go to
restaurants and the restaurants will
make money they'll pay employees they'll
buy stuff from food supply companies the
employees will go out and spend money at
other local businesses the food supply
companies seeing more demand from
restaurants will start ordering more
food from producers and the economic
activity will resume traveling will you
know then increase but increased air
travel will mean that people are going
to be places they don't live which means
they will demand hotel stays and on and
on and on now a reasonable question
would be and one that we should be
asking is there a way to prevent these
recessions in the first place now
preventing them altogether is tough and
there's a difference between a medically
based recession like coronavirus and
something like we saw in 2008
financial crisis there is no doubt that
we could organize economies in a way
that would soften these recessions and
make them less severe there are some
realities about our economic system um
there are booms and busts that's how
capitalism works and we have a
capitalism in the United States that is
not nearly regulated enough there is no
incentive in systems like ours to be
proactive proactive means you're
spending money you might not need to
spend and you're reducing your profits
in the immediate that we being proactive
is not incentivized by the system that
we have we are reactive so when the boom
turns to a bust it's really big and a
ton of people suffer greatly in the last
three months we learned about this many
systems that feel strong low
unemployment high stock market high
consumer confidence looked like a very
strong infrastructure it was really
quite fragile in about a two-week period
it imploded if all along we had a more
solid infrastructure we would suffer not
nearly as much during these downturns so
for example if everybody had healthcare
not connected to their employer losing a
job during a pandemic would be less of a
crisis it would still be a crisis but it
would be less of a crisis if health
insurance was not tied to employment
another example if we had universal
basic income or something like it
jobs guarantee whatever flavor you like
the loss of jobs or reductions in wages
would be less problematic
it wouldn't be irrelevant but it would
be less urgently problematic and the
government would not be in as much of a
position of acutely having to figure out
we got to start sending out checks
direct deposits debit prepaid debit
cards all this different stuff it would
be less of a crisis so the the lesson
that hopefully we would learn here is we
can't prevent a future pandemic from a
novel virus could happen again it likely
will happen again we can't prevent any
up and down in the economy even if we
ensure by you know putting it in
different insurance policies there are
business cycles and there are
going to be ups and downs but what
Social Democrats like me want is more
investment from the fruits of when
things are going well to put in place
social insurance policies that will
raise the standard of living for
everybody get more people off of that
borderline paycheck-to-paycheck
situation where if you don't work for
two weeks you now are unable to meet
your basic expenses let's make the
system less fragile for when things like
this happen in the future okay if you
are protesting now or if you plan to
protest someday you should really know
your rights what is the law and what is
beyond the law so that you can be
prepared to advocate for yourself and
others if you see protesters rights
being violated and so that you can
remain safe now I know I don't even have
to say this but of course if you break
the law including by damaging property
or attacking people you are at risk of
getting arrested and of getting the crap
kicked out of you by the way the way
things seem to be going with police and
nothing in this video is meant to help
people break the law the point is to
understand the law and understand what
you're legally allowed to do so first of
all the core of this is that the First
Amendment of the to the Constitution of
the United States grants you the right
to assemble and to use your voice to
protest using your voice includes things
like holding signs as well it is legal
for law enforcement to ban protesters
from certain physical spaces for example
if law enforcement says you can't walk
on the highway to protest and there's
already most states have rules against
walking on the highway anyway and you do
it you can get arrested for that if
there is a curfew and you ignore it to
protest you can get arrested where
things get tricky is in the gray area
when you have 99 percent of a protest
being peaceful and one percent starts
breaking the law the police do have the
right to clear the entire protest and
you can get arrested even if you weren't
doing anything wrong
if after police have said it's time to
go you stick around now police are not
supposed to immediately start arresting
and tear gassing and hit
people with batons if they say protests
has to end they wait five seconds and
they start beating the crap out of
people they're supposed to provide a
reasonable amount of time for people to
get out of the area and if you are what
clearly walking away you also should not
be bothered or attacked by police now
this is as you can imagine dangerous
because these rules can be misused
police can incite a couple of people to
break the law to then justify clearing
an entire protest that's a way in which
police can misuse these rules but
understand that when part of a protest
has gone bad legally I'm not saying
morally legally police can clear the
entire area now in terms of where you
can protest I mentioned highways could
be off-limits that would not be
considered a limitation of your First
Amendment rights if police say you can't
walk on the highway and do your protests
there there are states that require
permits if you're going to be in the
street or sometimes on the sidewalk if
you're not going to be moving and you're
going to be blocking traffic now a
pedestrian traffic generally you do not
need permits to protest while walking
along sidewalks or even in streets
sometimes if you are not obstructing
traffic depends on the state it's very
hard to protest on a road without
obstructing traffic so the road protests
almost always do need a permit generally
speaking public spaces can be protest
locations that include sidewalks and
parks and the like doesn't mean you can
do it without a permit in some states
you must know the laws of your state
anytime that you block the passage of
people or cars and this includes on
sidewalks you can be arrested if you
refuse to move understand that and again
this can be misused by police police
will sometimes say you're blocking
pedestrian traffic and then say and
because of that it's time to wrap it up
and then you stay and you get arrested
even though traffic may not actually
have been blocked police are supposed to
provide a reasonable opportunity to
comply and that includes sufficient time
and a clear unobstructed exit path we
had reports from yesterday
that protestors were sort of corralled
onto one of the bridges in between
Manhattan and Brooklyn I believe the
Manhattan Bridge and that would be in
violation of if you say it's time to go
you have to provide an unobstructed exit
path and time to exit now this means
that they can't say the party's over and
within 15 seconds start arresting people
but it is sometimes misused by police to
claim we issued a dispersal order and
they didn't move um quick note about
government buildings government
buildings can be exceptions they there's
sort of public buildings in a sense that
doesn't mean you can necessarily protest
inside and that varies by state very
important if you want to show up and
record with your phone or with a camera
or whatever you can record what is going
on in public and you can record police
no matter what they tell you again the
trick to watch out for is that if by
recording you are impeding police where
you've decided to stand if you're
getting in the way of what police are
doing they can argue you are interfering
with police you're obstructing law
enforcement as you can imagine that can
also be misused and you can find
examples of police saying that somebody
who's really not obstructing is
obstructing by virtue of where they're
standing to record the advice we
generally see is stand on the sidewalk
to record if the altercation is
happening on the sidewalk make sure that
you're not in the way of police now in
terms of recording you are also
protesting in a public space meaning you
can be recorded your picture can be
taken your face could be published in
media without your consent understand
that when you go to a protest you're not
starting an altercation because
someone's filming you but they do film
you and then that is used somewhere that
is legal because you are out in public
at a protest police do have pretty broad
rights to maintain law and order and
uphold local laws and this can sometimes
be Mis applied to filming be aware
police can't tell you that you have to
turn over your phone they can't force
you to show them stuff on your phone
they need a warrant signed by a judge in
order to do that now if police approach
you because you are recording certainly
remind the police that recording in a
public space is number one of course
legal and number two does not count as
reasonable suspicion to believe you have
committed a crime in other words if
police say they're there approaching you
because you're acting suspiciously and
all you're doing is filming filming does
not count as reasonable suspicion if you
do break the law and get arrested the
normal search and seizure rules would
apply if police tell you you've got a
delete a video from your phone that is
not a lawful order from police and you
don't have to do it if police want to
search your backpack or your wallet or
your fanny pack before or after an
arrest you're under no obligation to
allow it and you can even say I do not
consent to a search of my property
police typically are allowed to Pat you
down in some states you do have to give
police your name but you are not
required to give any other information
remember counter-protesters that might
not agree with you also have free speech
rights and police are supposed to treat
both protesters and counter protesters
equally according to the ACLU police are
permitted if they identify antagonistic
groups police are permitted to keep
those groups separated but they should
allow them to be within sight and sound
of each other otherwise you're not
really able to protest you're not really
able to counter protest if you can only
do it out of earshot and visible range
of the people you are protesting so then
a few notes on police interactions if
police approached you and you and want
to talk to you you don't have to talk to
them but don't resist of course it's
better not to run away but simply ask am
I being detained or am I free to go
if they say you were not free to go you
are able to inquire what is the crime
I'm suspected of having committed that
has caused you to detain me if you do
get arrested you also don't have to say
anything again in some states you do
have to state your name but in many
states you don't the degree of
cooperation you want to exhibit is up to
you depends on what you've been doing
depends on your
at anytime you can ask for a lawyer and
they are required to provide you one now
can you be fired by your employer for
being at a protest even if you didn't do
anything illegal even if your
participation is protected by the
Constitution
unfortunately the answer answers it
depends it depends on the state you live
and work in it depends on what kind of
job you have it depends on what kind of
agreement you have in place with your
employer if you have one a lot of people
don't really have such agreements and
that one is more complicated and you
should really discuss it with a lawyer
or legal aid service but there are many
circumstances in which your employer can
dismiss you merely for having
participated in a constitutionally
protected protest very important to
understand the law and your rights when
it comes to that let me know if I missed
anything important make sure you are
following me on Twitter at D Pakman and
make sure you're subscribed to the daily
audio podcast on iTunes stitcher Spotify
and Google Play or anywhere you prefer
to get your podcast we'll take a quick
break and be back after this the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are april Braddock and Michelle Metz
thanks to April and Michelle for the
support also a big thank you to David
Fedak who has been a member for almost
five years and is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day I have to
tell you about something interesting
that's happened in the last 48 hours I
received a bunch of emails and tweets
from people saying you know David I
wasn't planning to vote for Biden
because he's not a progressive I don't
believe in choosing the lesser of two
evils but after Donald Trump's
authoritarian nightmare of a declaration
on Monday night about deploying the
military to States I realize I have to
vote for Joe Biden this these last 72 or
so hours from Donald Trump for many of
my viewers have become a breaking point
now I don't want you to write to me I
don't need you to write to me and say
not me David I'm still never voting for
Biden okay I'm not talking about you
what I'm telling you is that I have seen
nothing since the start of this election
that has triggered so many emails from
people saying I was not on board with
Biden for this reason or for that reason
but over the last three days I've
realized I have to vote for Biden in
November because this has gone too far
check out some of the tweets that were
sent to me here's one quote I despise
Biden and the Democrats still do but at
least he won't try to label millions of
our citizens as terrorists and SiC the
military on us I will crawl over broken
glass to vote for him in the fall
another tweet quote I've been a Bernie
supporter before people knew he existed
yet I am vote blue to save America 2020
as a history professor I've seen this
before when you have a chance to halt
fascism you do it then fight for a
leftist push question what will we do
when Trump refuses to leave the White
House another tweet saying quote
same here that press-conference BS was
the nail in the coffin so listen this is
logical we are now seeing this nascent
authoritarianism come full circle and I
want to add something that somebody
tweeted to me that I believe is very
important in the context of this
conversation I got a tweet which said
quote they need to be encouraged and not
shamed and that is exactly right we were
never going to shame people out of
sitting aside in November it wasn't
going to work I've been talking about
the the futility of voter shaming for
several weeks if not months now and I'm
not going to shame them now I I have no
interest in doing this I told you so
stuff with the never Biden folks who are
realizing this is a crisis and we've got
to remove Trump what I'm gonna say is
I'm thrilled I'm thrilled and I knew you
would come around you are seeing the
reality of the situation for what it is
let's get together and defeat Donald
Trump I'm glad to have you no shame here
no I told you so here
none of this stuff I encourage everybody
to do the exact same thing I know you
know the YouTube comments people will
say David you're so stupid I'm stung
always never Biden I'm not talking about
you and we don't need everyone we just
need some people to realize staying home
is not okay and right now this we we
need to remove Donald Trump if the last
72 hours haven't made that sickeningly
clear then I don't know that there's
anything left that would convince you
and in fact I think again without shame
with total peace and love and curiosity
I would go back to the folks that are
still never Abidin and say I want to
engage with you now that Donald Trump
has continued the satori authoritarian
slide what else do you need to say I've
got to do it I've got to vote for Biden
is it some specific policy position is
there anything Trump could do that would
get you to say okay now he's clearly bad
enough that I'm going to vote for Biden
rather than staying home or voting third
party or whatever I
hear from you and I hope that you will
let me know Donald Trump has been
tweeting attacks on protesters from the
White House for days while offering up a
suggestion that the military go in and
use more force against protesters
meanwhile Democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden has been meeting
with protesters he gave a very good
speech yesterday about the state of the
race as well as police relations in this
country and we now have Democratic
senator Elizabeth Warren joining the
protest marches yesterday marching with
her husband and her absolutely
delightful dog a Golden Retriever named
Bailey here is Warren marching of course
with a mask asked by a protester why is
Donald Trump bringing in the military
Warren says because he's wrong people
are protesting peacefully check it out
it is a little bit difficult to
understand all of the audio because
people are wearing masks but I think
you're gonna get the gist of it
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth Warren not being shy about
what is going on she tweeted on Monday
quote the President of the United States
tear-gassed peaceful protesters in order
to clear the way for a useless photo-op
outside the White House just after
vowing to activate the military against
our own people lives and democracy are
in danger I like this you know ok she's
a senator she's not gonna say everything
you or I would necessarily say but she's
being strong and clear here and how
about Bailey the dog at the protest it
really just doesn't get better than a
nice dog joining a movement for sanity
and reason so what's going on with
Warren as VP you all know last week I
interviewed congressman ro Khanna and he
said he believes Warren is the best
choice for VP a Joe Biden is
increasingly getting pressure not to
pick Elizabeth Warren from different
camps okay there are some people who
don't want Warren to be the VP because
they don't like her wealth tax and they
don't want her wealth tax to be made
into the law the reality is that
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax is very
unlikely to be made into the law even if
Elizabeth Warren is vice president
please understand that it's not even
clear Joe Biden supports that there's
another contingent that wants Joe Biden
to choose a black vice-president now
remember Joe Biden already committed to
choosing a female vice president
yesterday on the bonus show we talked
about the call for Joe Biden now to pick
a black female vice president I believe
that the top choices in terms of who's
likely to get it for a black female VP
would be Kamala Harris and maybe Val
Demmings now Kamala Harris is hugely
problematic because of her actions as
California Attorney General given what's
going on right now with the protests it
strikes me as maybe a bad idea to pick
Kamala Harris if in two months the Prout
have died down maybe it's something that
would be less problematic from a PR
perspective although her track record as
California AG is not good
Val Demmings on the other hand would be
an interesting choice
she's a congresswoman from Florida with
a Florida or Georgia now I believe it's
Florida with a law enforcement
background and I think that that would
be a very interesting pick now there are
people talking about Nina Turner or
Stacey Abrams I know not everybody in my
audience knows who they are
I don't see it as even remotely likely
that Joe Biden picks Nina Turner or
Stacey Abrams so let me know your
thoughts who do you think Biden is most
likely to select versus who would you
like Joe Biden to select interested in
hearing from you you can let me know on
Twitter at D Pakman okay a little bit of
election news I have really good news
for people disgusting extremist
ideologue right winger Congressman Steve
King from Iowa lost I'm sorry from
Indiana lost his Republican primary last
and sorry Iowa lost his primary
yesterday and is being kicked out of
Congress in January this is truly a
disgusting guy and I am so glad in the
midst of just terrible things going on
in our country to be able to tell you
about something good that has taken
place
they voted yesterday Steve King has been
ousted by state senator randy Feenstra
King has a history of racially toxic
comments he once wax nostalgic about how
the term white supremacist doesn't
didn't used to be offensive
he is irrationally anti-immigrant he
once compared immigrants to dogs and
dirt in 2013 he said that young
documented immigrants have this is a
quote calves the size of cantaloupes
because they haul 75 pounds of marijuana
across the desert he wanted an
electrified fence between the us-mexico
border he's complained white people
aren't having enough babies to keep up
with the rapid reproduction of
minorities
he endorsed the white nationalists
running for the mayor of Toronto and he
also met with Austrian far-right
political party leaders a party that was
founded by a neo-nazi so he's a horrible
guy he was widely abandoned by the
Republican Party and that's why you know
this is not glorious news it's great
that King has lost but the person he
lost to Randy Feenstra is not great and
in fact what's scary is that Feenstra is
running on or ran on steve king is not
an effective ally for Donald Trump I can
be an effective ally for Donald Trump
and his big issues are to keep the Trump
tax cuts to protect Christian values not
exactly the best guy scary but hopefully
Trump himself will be removed in
November and Feenstra won't gather ever
get a chance to serve with Trump even
better by the way is that JD Shelton our
friend JD Shelton who unsuccessfully ran
to unseat Steve King back in 2018 is
running again so we don't have to see
Randy Feenstra win let's support JD
shulton great guy former professional
baseball player I interviewed him back
in 2018 he is running again
he is the Democrat running against Randy
Feenstra let's support him
excellent excellent candidate will have
continued coverage of yesterday's
election results on the david packard
show instagram page that's david pakman
show all one words on instagram the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Ted Conover who's an author
practicing immersion writing as well as
director of NYU's Arthur L Carter
journalism Institute I've actually
recommended one or two of Ted's books to
my audience in the past Ted I really
appreciate your time thanks for talking
to me so there are a lot of people in my
audience who may not immediately know
what we mean by immersion writing and
some of the work that you've done in
advance sometimes four years before you
will write a book certainly knew Jack
where you actually became a correctional
officer in order to tell the story of
what that's like
in coyotes you actually travel across
the us-mexico border with undocumented
immigrants and and even subsequently
work with them in multiple places in the
United States so first to just kind of
frame it when you start a project like
this what's the genesis of an idea how
do you think about your relationship to
the subject matter and start thinking
about how you'll carry the project out
sure I guess you could say my approach
is to try to go more in depth than a
regular journalist can I look for a
subject that matters to people maybe
it's mass incarceration maybe it's
immigration undocumented immigration or
homelessness and I think okay what a
journalist another has been able to do
to cast light on this topic and what
could I do if I were willing to
spend more time and get closer get my
hands dirty if needed and often the
answer has been I tried to go beyond the
sort of interview a journalist does
right asking the five W's and all that
and spend time living with somebody else
or doing what they do
so my first book is about railroad
tramps and I was still an undergraduate
in college and rode the rails
I met Mexicans while doing that and
using my high school Spanish realized
they would talk to me and in fact it
seemed open to it and it seemed open to
me hanging out and that became my my
second book called coyotes which you
mentioned and then yeah when I moved to
New York from Colorado gosh
20 years ago mass incarceration was all
over the news as it is again today and I
thought you know there's got to be a way
to get closer to the subject than just
you know calling up people on the phone
or doing interviews and ended up
applying for a job as a New York state
corrections officer which took about
three years to get and then I worked the
worked at sing-sing almost a year for
that book and the idea is yeah I get
closer I'm not a standard journalist
keeping my distance I'm I'm right in
there and you know sometimes distance is
good it lets you be a little more
objective but I tend to get subjective I
say you know I'm a I'm a CEO I'm scared
of this situation or I'm a CEO the guys
around me are angry and today I
understand it I feel kind of angry
myself and and so I I try to take notes
on what it feels like to be there in the
book new jack and also in some of the
the research I did preparing for the
interview
you talk about the perception that could
have been the one that your your
co-workers at sing-sing came away with
when they learned about the fact that
you were researching and ultimately
wrote a book about your experience there
that they might be mad at you they might
not like the fact that you essentially I
mean to call it it's not a ruse in the
sense that you really did go through the
training you really did work there you
nobody knew you weren't treated
differently because there was this book
coming at the end of the experience but
that maybe you took advantage in some
way that is not okay or that they would
in some way be displeased with the fact
that you were there not just as a
correctional officer but also as a
writer for sure what was I mean what is
there a fair critique to be made that
you were sort of using the resources of
training in order to end up writing a
book or do you find that not to be a
fair critique well you've asked a couple
of questions that last one is did I you
know somehow take advantage of the
resources of the state of New York just
to you know just to be able to write
something about it and in fact I stayed
on the job longer than the typical
trainee does most people drop out before
I did and I stuck with it so I think New
York State got their value from me it
was a good employee
I got good job ratings I tried really
hard to be a good corrections officer
and understand what that meant that's
one of two projects which you could call
undercover because I could not tell
people my full background or my real
agenda which was to write something
about this the other time I did that I
became a USDA meat inspector and a beef
plant in in Nebraska and that was
secretive too and if you do something in
a secretive way
a you are deceptive and deception is
best avoided in journalism but there are
times when in order to do something
important I think deception is warranted
not all journalists agree but there was
no other way I could understand the life
of a an officer a guard at sing-sing
without doing that job I had previously
actually gotten an assignment from The
New Yorker to write about SEOs upstate
and and then the state wouldn't let me
go to work with them they would let me
visit a single prison once for a short
guided tour 'but this is a big deal it's
a corrections as the second-largest
employer in New York State or was when I
was a CEO and how could how do you
justify keeping the public out so I felt
justified in getting the job secretly
and then you know every journalist faces
a moment of reckoning when the when the
what they've written comes out or what
they've produced on video the subjects
like it or they don't and they say it's
true or they say that's BS it's not
really different when you've done
something undercover people you write
about are still either gonna say that's
BS or they're gonna say yeah well
actually that's true and far and away
SEOs said that book is true you know
it's warts and all we don't look good in
the whole thing but I got credit for
doing the job myself and and for telling
the truth about it most angry was the
state of New York which put out a press
release urging aggrieved employees to
sue me if if they felt I had injured
them somehow and I think the people who
felt injured were the the state
corrections bureaucrats who's who felt
I'd snuck into their their prisons and
and talked about it which I wasn't
supposed to do one of the things in New
Jack that comes out which I think
couldn't possibly have come out if you
were just interviewing people is the
sort of many sides of the prototypical
correctional officer in the sense that
there's often conflict about their views
of the system there's conflict about the
views on even individual inmates as some
of the stories that you tell what else
was only possible in the telling of that
story because you were immersed as a
correctional officer that by
interviewing people simply could not
have been part of the story I'm really
happy you brought up that example
because to me that is what this approach
lets me do is look at a big fat
stereotype like the guard as brutal or
the guard as sadist and think and ask
out loud how much of that is true and
and you're right I found in some cases
gosh that guy's pretty bad but in lots
of other cases in fact in most cases
what I found was human beings trying to
keep something good in themselves alive
while being immersed in this negative
environment day after day after day like
it's a crummy job it brings out the
worst in them it brought out the worst
in me as my wife observed it showed her
my inner disciplinarian which I had
actually never tried to cultivate but
that's kind of what the job asks you to
do is say no all day long to your fellow
human beings so the to get to your
question more particularly working at
sing-sing put me in a group of officers
of color and there's no way I could have
learned the things I learned about their
lives otherwise I'm I remember the day
I'm talking to the crew I worked with in
B Block it's this giant housing block
more than 600 prisoners we had like
fifteen minutes outside the mess hall
before we had to start frisking
prisoners and a guy named Alcantara
who's Dominican and lives near New York
City described double parking outside
his mom's building because she was
moving and he had his minivan and he ran
inside her Lobby to pick something up
and as he's running out undercover
officers thinking he's part of a drug
deal tackle him hmm and I heard this a
version of this story like six different
times these are officers of color I work
with who are being pulled over by police
on traffic stops or they're being
stopped by Undercovers in Harlem because
they are people of color and that makes
a big impression you know and I wouldn't
have been able to tell stories like that
had I not done the job myself one of the
things that I took away from it in
hearing you know you described in the
book kind of your personality
transformation as you described and your
wife dealing with it is that maybe there
really is more to this idea that the
focus on individuals in systems even now
like with the unrest and protests that
we are seeing the the focus on
individuals is relevant because people
are people as individuals but we
shouldn't ignore the effect that systems
have and that was a really big takeaway
for me
yeah the system makes you act a certain
way let's say you are a person convicted
of a crime who has had friends of
different races you know you're from a
place where it was cool making friends
who who didn't look like you well you're
going to prison and that that stuff
doesn't fly in a lot of prisons you have
to stick with your own kind
you know prisons are racially polarized
and then their ideological II polarized
and they're organized by gang and and so
prisoners inmates have to act a certain
way
and then so do officers let's say I'm an
officer who thinks it's okay to have a
conversation with a prisoner like just
you know how we did I mean that was
something you described yeah I thought
well that should be that's a good idea
right that's how you manage people you
talk to them there's a whole bunch of
officers who who think that's a terrible
idea that that you're gonna you're gonna
get a reputation as the inmates friend
right a guy who won't uphold the rules
and and in fact and there were some
cases like that where some officers were
just too friendly and you think whoa
what's what's that about because a
certain distance is appropriate but yeah
you're in this system where your uniform
defines how you interact with other
people and and you're one of a group of
people whether you're a prisoner or an
officer you're one of a group and you
have to act in accordance with the
standards of that group and gosh when I
see officers now standing shoulder to
shoulder to repel demonstrators I'm
always thinking okay how many of them
are spoiling for a fight because you can
tell some of them are right you know all
of their hearts are beating bump bump
bump on there like okay is it when's it
gonna start how long can i restrain
myself what are who's gonna stick up for
me
if rock hits me in the head but then you
know there's a whole bunch of them who
are like oh my god let me just get home
in one piece and back to my family and
my my toddler and right I I didn't
really sign up to be in a riot and but
how is how are those people going to act
when when it comes to violence
how will they will they respond to their
training with restraint will they
respond to their
you know that their ancient brain and
start firing a weapon or flailing with a
gun the the whole question of how you
act when you're a law enforcement
officer and part of a group that's under
stress is super important and matters so
much today and and yeah so that's that's
kind of the thing I wanted to to find
out about let's pause the conversation
there on our podcast but we'll have the
full conversation with head on our on
our youtube channel the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
I have some stunning tweets for you
today of Donald Trump actually blaming
the guy in the White House for protests
happening around our country now of
course the guy in the White House when
Trump was doing this was named Barack
Obama and Trump will never actually take
responsibility when it's him but it is
another example of just the blistering
hypocrisy so back in 2014 there were
protests in the United States over the
killing of black teenager Michael Brown
Donald Trump tweeted just a treasure
trove of attacks on Barack Obama for
those protests including quote our
country is totally fractured and with
our weak leadership in Washington you
can expect Ferguson type riots and
looting in other places Trump also
tweeting and this one is extra special
can you imagine what Putin and all of
our friends and enemies throughout the
world are saying about the u.s. as they
watched the ferguson riot well imagine
what they're saying now as we have a
level of unrest that makes what happened
around Ferguson look like child's play
while Donald Trump's suggestion is
bringing the military to repress
protests even more aggressively what are
they saying right now well we know what
they're saying and we've heard from a
number of those leaders including
Canada's Justin Trudeau and they're
horrified another Trump tweet quote as
China and the rest of the world continue
to rip off the US economically they
laugh at us and our president over the
riots in Ferguson again what are they
doing right now now of course this time
around when the civil unrest is orders
of magnitude bigger than what we had in
2014 it's combined with a hundred year
pandemic suddenly none of it has
anything to do with Donald Trump it's
everybody else's fault in this case now
I told you yesterday that Donald Trump's
strategy has ironically been CCCP just a
coincidence that those are the initials
cccp and what this means is confuse
about what's actually happening in our
country that's step one
number to conflate and Trump has been
conflating and so is Cayley McKenna nian
other trumpets conflate protesters
looters rioters and insiders criticize
and this means passed the buck past the
blame to governor's to Democrats to
protesters to whoever else Trump can
blame and then lastly the P in CCCP is
to pander pander to his Trump is base
much of which loves authoritarianism and
that you know we're gonna have a
voicemail later on about the hypocrisy
but you know all of these people who
claim to support Trump and who are
owning guns because they fear a
tyrannical government will be swept in
and they will need their rifles to
defend themselves they are saying very
little about the deployment of State
National Guard's about Donald Trump's
threat to deploy federal military assets
to States in contrast or in opposition
to what it is that governors are asking
for and the really sad and tragic thing
about this approach is that many of his
followers have fallen for the idea that
anything good that happens is thanks to
trump and anything bad that happens is
somebody else's fault if you can blame
Obama that's great you can blame
Democrats if you can blame China you can
blame the so-called fake news media
that's all great so what we need right
now what we lack is leadership empathy
understanding and a really steady hand
at times like these Trump can't lead
Trump has no empathy Trump doesn't
understand so many things and he has the
opposite of a steady hand he has a
completely erratic hand Trump is telling
cops don't be too nice Trump is telling
governor's you guys are jerks
Trump is calling the protesters thugs
Trump is conflating antia and protesters
and I did want to say one or the other
thing about the blaming of governor's
notice that it is now a regular for
Donald Trump
you know on coronavirus when it became
impossible to defend his failed testing
protocol he said you know really testing
is up to the governors in the end
they've got to figure out how to test
enough people for coronavirus it's the
same thing now he is saying it's the
weak governors who aren't being tough
enough
with the protesters blaming weak
governor's from the White House and on
Twitter is like an arsonist blaming
firefighters for not putting out a fire
that they started it makes absolutely no
sense we are dealing with protests over
police brutality and Trump's big idea
after a weekend of silence is to say hey
let's be more brutal with the protesters
and then he blames governors for not
doing so it's all backwards my friends
it's all completely and utterly
backwards and it's why we have to end it
in November we have to talk about this
talking point being used by some on the
right and even some on the left about
so-called outside protesters in the
civil unrest that we're seeing across
the country right now in dozens of urban
areas so I'm going to tell you what's
being said I'm going to tell you the
truth and then I'm going to tell you
what the most important takeaway is from
all of this which is that it doesn't
actually matter if protesters are coming
from so-called
the outside so the write regularly talks
about so-called outside protesters
because their priority is to make it
seem like there's not really a concern
in our country about police brutality in
the communities where the protests are
happening so when the right insists the
protesters are coming from outside the
city from somewhere else they can
disqualify and ignore the activism that
is actually motivating protesters and
they can say you know these are
provocateurs these are looters and
rioters burglars people who are there
for nefarious reasons but most
importantly what they want to argue by
saying people are coming in from outside
the cities is they want to argue that
not that many people are actually
concerned about police brutality which
was the catalyst for these protests
you've also got a little slice of the
left where you've seen the outside
protesters talking point used in the
context of framing outsiders as the
right-wing astroturf whether it's white
nationalists pretending to be an tyfa or
in order to make an tyfa and protesters
kind of amorphous or look bad or
whatever else you're seeing less of it
but it's still also not the
thing because here's the truth number
one in terms of those getting arrested
the reports that we've seen are that
most of the arrests are people who live
in the cities or metro areas where the
protests are happening so in Minnesota
there was a report about 20 of percent
of the arrests were Outsiders in Detroit
similar numbers about 80 percent of the
arrests were from the Detroit metro area
so first of all it is factually untrue
that a huge number at least of the
troublemakers are from outside areas but
here are the two really important
takeaways first of all it would make
sense that the troublemakers politics
aside are from the outside why well
there's that phrase about dogs don't go
to the bathroom where they eat or
something like that intuitively of
course people are more likely to cause
trouble and destroy stuff where they
don't live it says nothing about motive
or justification for the protests
whatsoever but it makes sense that
you're more likely to destroy a place
that you don't actually live in but
here's the most important takeaway who
cares if they're coming from the outside
you can still care about police
brutality if you come into a city from
somewhere else mass rallies happen in
urban centers and population centers
protests happen where there are people
if you live in northern rural Indiana
there aren't any sizeable protests there
because there's such little population
density it makes perfect sense that you
would head into Chicago for example to
be part of a larger protest it doesn't
mean you don't care about police
brutality it doesn't mean you're there
to commit a crime or to attack people or
to loot it just means people are
protesting where there are people so I
was reminded of this debate that
happened around Barack Obama this is he
really a Christian or is he is some kind
of secret Muslim and at some point :
Powell came out and said the question of
whether he is or is not Muslim is
irrelevant Muslims can still be
President it would change nothing about
his policies if he were Muslim and in
the same way here there is nothing
invalid about protesters from out of
town much of this country is
the protests are limited to a few dozen
large urban areas of course you're going
to have people from different places in
cities protesting because that's where
the protests are taking place so we've
got to take back this talking point we
can't allow the right or the left to
miss the forest for the trees just
arguing about the protesters are from in
or out of the city the looters are from
in or out of the city people are going
to cities because that's where the
protests are happening and there's
nothing wrong with that
okay here's an interesting voicemail our
number is two one nine two david p with
a very interesting question about where
are all those Obama is going to declare
martial law people right now hey David I
just wanted to say that remember a few
years ago when Obama was president yeah
and he had all those right-wing you're
saying that he was gonna declare martial
law and take away people's guns yes
unleash the Black Hawk helicopters and
all that nonsense right well where are
those people now like I don't get how
they could see what's happening now and
not be against it
oh I see how it was always partisan
hackery they never really care about
that stuff that it's very very simple
they're not complaining now about Trump
because when they see Oh Trump is going
to come out and repress protests with
the military they like it they like it
was never about principles it was never
about suspending habeas corpus or
whatever it was that they said it was
just partisan politics and it's being
very boldly exposed right now we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about bicycles becoming the new
toilet paper they are flying off the
shelves during the corona virus pandemic
and much more don't miss today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a
member at join pakman.com and remember
every day the David Pakman show audio
podcast is available get it on Spotify
stitcher Google Play podcasts iTunes
wherever you want
don't miss the podcast and
we'll see you on the bonus show
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video